[Música]
Bolivia está viviendo semanas de intriga
miedo incertidumbre el país se enfrenta
a una situación política y económica
límite La pregunta es fue de Bolivia
quebrar qué está sucediendo en este país
andino tras El triunfal regreso al poder
del más el movimiento al socialismo de
Evo Morales queridos amigos amigas En
este vídeo os vamos a dar todas las
respuestas arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os hago una pregunta qué tienen en común
Lenin Moreno Alberto Fernández y Luis
Arce 321 Exacto los tres son Herederos
de los grandes líderes del conocido como
socialismo del siglo XXI pero sabéis que
tienen algo más en común los tres
salieron ranas es decir que no se
conformaron con la condición de ser
líderes sumisos de sus grandes padrinos
políticos Lenin Moreno se enfrentó a
Rafael Correa a Alberto Fernández ha
terminado fatal con el kirchnerismo y
Luis Arce bueno digamos que ahora la
lucha de Evo Morales por Regresar al
poder le ha hecho chocar de frente con
su delfín que por supuesto pues no está
dispuesto a devolverle el sillón de
mando el resultado al inquietante crisis
económica la que se enfrenta a Bolivia
tenemos que sumar también una feroz
guerra política entre el gobierno y la
oposición y otra entre los propios
miembros del partido de gobierno
hablamos de un enorme caos que está
poniendo contra las cuerdas el futuro
del país estas queridos amigos amigas
son las tres grandes crisis que amenazan
con tumbar Bolivia atentos
[Música]
el movimiento en falso de Evo Morales
hasta la fecha Evo Morales ha sido el
presidente constitucional que más tiempo
ha permanecido en el poder en Bolivia de
forma continuada Morales tuvo las
riendas del país entre los años 2006 y
2019 y no solo eso su propia figura se
ha convertido en el icono de la política
boliviana Claro que no todo dura para
siempre Evo Morales hizo todo lo posible
para poder presentarse a las elecciones
del 2019 y era algo que en principio la
Constitución no le permitía ya os lo
contamos en visualpolitik Evo quería
presentarse Sí o sí así que en 2016
impulsó un referéndum para poder
postularse a un tercer mandato un
referéndum que perdió Pero por supuesto
eso no le iba a detener en 2017 su
partido el más presentó un recurso ante
el tribunal constitucional denunciando
Que bueno que la limitación de mandato
violaba a sus derechos humanos
y sabéis que sorpresa el mismo tribunal
que tiene la misión de hacer cumplir la
Constitución decidió saltársela haciendo
caso omiso de un precepto muy claro en
la propia Constitución y así autorizó
Evo Morales a ser candidato Claro que la
cosa terminó como el rosario de la
Aurora las elecciones del 2019 fueron un
auténtico desastre que por qué pues
fijaos las manipulaciones y
irregularidades señaladas no permiten
tener certeza sobre el margen de
Victoria del candidato Morales sobre el
candidato mesa por el contrario a partir
del abrumadora evidencia encontrada Lo
que sí es posible afirmar es que ha
habido una serie de operaciones dolosas
encaminadas alterar la voluntad
expresada en las urnas análisis sobre
las elecciones generales de Bolivia de
la Organización de Estados Americanos la
misión de expertos electorales de la
Unión Europea pudo comprobar que varias
actas deberían haber sido anuladas casos
donde se agregó votos al más informe de
la misión de observadores electorales de
la Unión Europea queridos amigos amigas
las elecciones estuvieron repletas de
irregularidades y ya lo veis tanto la
Organización de Estados Americanos como
europea fueron contundentes había
indicios muy claros de pucherazo tanto
que el propio Morales Se comprometió a
repetirlas pero no fue suficiente el 10
de noviembre de ese mismo año 2019 en
medio de enormes protestas el mandatario
se vio obligado a dimitir se trasladó a
México pidiendo el asilo político y
denunció un golpe político policial en
su contra y yo dije yo nunca voy a
renunciar quiero que sepan mis hermanas
y hermanos estoy renunciando para que
mesa y Camacho no sigan haciendo patear
quemar sus casas de mis hermanos duerme
eso por eso hemos decidido de anunciar a
nuestros cargos ahora me he convencido
Como algunos técnicos de la oea
están al servicio no de las familias
Humildes sino de grupos de poder entendí
perfectamente
[Música]
desde 2019 y las denuncias de fraude se
produjeron enormes protestas y
manifestaciones la tensión y la
violencia no paraba de crecer los
manifestantes incluso asaltaron la
propia casa Diego Morales en Cochabamba
finalmente el 12 de noviembre y la
entonces segunda vicepresidenta de la
cámara de senadores giannine añez fue
proclamada presidenta del estado
plurinacional de Bolivia
anier ratificó la convocatoria de
elecciones pero la pandemia de la Kobe
19 obligó a retrasar todo el calendario
electoral al final los comicios no se
celebraron hasta el 18 de octubre del
2020 Fue una carrera en la que los
partidos opositores al más pecaron
Quizás de exceso de confianza para que
os hagáis una idea llegaron fragmentados
con dos candidaturas diferentes la del
ex presidente Carlos mesa por un lado y
la de Luis Camacho el líder político de
la provincia de Santa Cruz por otro
enfrente tuvieron al más con un
candidato nuevo 19 de enero de 2020 Evo
Morales anunció que Luis Arce será el
candidato a presidente del más en las
nuevas elecciones de Bolivia y ya os
podéis imaginar lo que pasó con el
55,11% de los votos Luis Arce luchó el
exministro de finanzas de Morales ganó
las elecciones Y no sólo eso también se
hizo con el control del legislativo 21
de los 26 escaños del senado y 75 de los
130 asientos del Congreso quedaron otra
vez bajo el control del más la oposición
había fracasado a lo grande sin embargo
esperad un momento porque la victoria no
iba a suponer para el más la
tranquilidad que muchos auguraban la
lucha entre el expresidente y el nuevo
presidente estaba servida atentos
[Música]
delfín o tiburón
Luis Arce fue algo así como el gestor en
la sombra de la economía boliviana
durante la presidencia de Evo Morales
bajo el liderazgo absoluto del
expresidente digamos que Arce encontró
cierto margen de maniobra y lo cierto Es
que las cosas empezaron con buen pie
fijaos metidos de diciembre de 2005 en
una decisión histórica el fmi le perdonó
la deuda a Bolivia el fondo monetario
internacional anunció ayer que el
primero de enero de 2006 condonará la
deuda de 19 países incluidos Nicaragua
Bolivia y Honduras fue un regalo
equivalente a casi el 3% del pib
boliviano Pues bien Apenas unos días
después de este regalo Evo Morales
nombró a Luis Arce como ministro de
hacienda y tres años después le entregó
el súper Ministerio de economía y
finanzas Arce cada vez tenía Más peso y
más poder durante su primera etapa como
ministro se centró en renegociar los
contratos de exploración y explotación
de las commodities como el gas natural
los metales o los derivados agrícolas y
sabéis que las cosas siguieron saliendo
a las mil maravillas por aquel entonces
los precios de las commodities se
dispararon a nivel internacional lo que
provocó un contexto inmejorable para la
economía boliviana el dinero comenzó a
entrar en las arcas públicas como nunca
antes había entrado fueron los años
dorados de la minería boliviana de
repente amigos entró tanto dinero en el
país que el saldo por cuenta corriente
pasó de estar en negativo a llegar a
registrar dos dígitos en positivo además
A diferencia de países como Venezuela
Bolivia fue mucho más prudente con el
gasto público Así que la deuda externa
se desplomó y el gobierno tuvo ingentes
recursos para gastar en todo tipo de
proyectos de esta forma la narrativa del
gobierno de Evo Morales fue muy clara
gracias al socialismo antiimperialista
del más Bolivia vuelve a ser una nación
libre soberana y próspera Que luego el
origen de toda esa prosperidad fuera la
venta de recursos naturales al bloque
hegemónico imperialista occidental bueno
eso ya es otra historia sea como sea la
cuestión es que las cosas mejoraron
[Música]
y ahora es cuando muchos os preguntaréis
Pero por qué demonios en visualpolitik
nos están hablando de los presuntos
logros del gobierno de Morales es que
acaso visualpolitik está siendo
financiada por la industria cocalera de
Bolivia pues evidentemente no pero lo
que importa aquí es que tras este
contexto económico que nutrió la enorme
popularidad Evo Morales estaba un
arquitecto político con nombre y
apellidos una identidad que poco a poco
empezó a resonar en la opinión pública
estamos hablando por supuesto de Luis
Arce 10 de octubre de 2014 el hombre
detrás del éxito de Evo Morales Arce
concibióticas para el sector gacifero
que generaron grandes ingresos al tiempo
que controló el gasto a partir de mayo
de 2006 el gobierno exigió que las
empresas energéticas extranjeras pagaran
32% adicional en impuestos y regalías
Marx dice para lograr el Salto al
socialismo hay que desarrollar las
fuerzas productivas es lo que estamos
haciendo Luis Arce en 2014 su imagen
cada vez era más reconocida sin embargo
en 2017 tuvo que renunciar a su
ministerio por un cáncer de riñón su
estado de salud se complicó y al final
tuvo que ser tratado en Brasil pero pese
a todo en 2019 retornó al ministerio
Aunque lo cierto Es que duró muy poco en
el cargo porque tuvo que salir del
gobierno junto a Morales tras la
denuncia del pucherazo sin embargo
cuando más tarde su nombre apareció para
hacerse con la candidatura del más a la
presidencia el acierto de Evo Morales
parecía muy claro Arce no sólo tenía una
buenísima valoración general sino que
además no infundía miedo entre los
empresarios del país además se
presentaba a sí mismo como todo un
experto económico en mitad del
Torbellino que suponía la pandemia así
que por supuesto ganó
y sabéis que el problema para Evo
Morales Es que desde el primer momento
el candidato que era conocido como el
delfín pasó a convertirse en una especie
de Depredador con agenda propia fijaos
digo no tendrá ningún papel en nuestro
gobierno Tendremos que aplicar medidas
de austeridad no hay otra opción si no
tenemos suficientes ingresos para cubrir
nuestros gastos actuales Luis arte y
virtual presidente de Bolivia 10 de
noviembre de 2020 Luis Arce nombra un
gabinete distanciado de Evo Morales por
supuesto queridos amigos amigas eso de
pretender dejar al antiguo líder en el
banquillón no le iba a salir gratis al
nuevo presidente justo aquí fue cuando
se puso en marcha una lucha fratricida a
cara de perro dentro del propio más una
lucha que poco a poco se ha ido
reproduciendo y que hoy ya es casi tan
pública como la ruptura entre Shakira y
Piqué no me creéis pues atentos 8 de
septiembre de 2022 Evo Morales acusa a
ministros de Bolivia de ejecutar un plan
negro contra él el líder del mas
aseverado que miembros del gobierno han
contratado a guerreros digitales para
atacarlo a través de las redes sociales
Nosotros somos bomberos y el Lucho Arce
no reconoce la ministra de presidencia
no reconoce como hacemos esfuerzo para
que no haya conflictos y ellos los
ministros buscan conflictos Evo Morales
cuando Evo Morales con lo cual Luis
arcede lo hizo pensando en su propio
regreso al poder y eso es exactamente lo
que persigue en las elecciones de 2025
Evo Morales quiere hacerse de nuevo con
los mandos del país sin embargo hay un
problema Luis Arce también aspira a ser
elegido se vende como el cambio
regeneracional a la etapa ya caduca del
más de Morales así que ya lo veis el
conflicto está servido y todo apunta a
que las cosas dentro del mar se Irán
poniendo cada vez más y más tensa a
medida claro estaba que se acerquen las
elecciones ahora bien No penséis ni por
un momento que esta es la única crisis
política que vive Bolivia atentos
de furia
recordemos que en noviembre de 2019 las
protestas contra Morales fueron tan
grandes que no se salvó ni su casa por
supuesto todo ese descontento de gran
parte de la sociedad boliviana no
desapareció solo se recluyó la sociedad
boliviana Sigue estando fuertemente
fragmentada lo que resulta en todo un
polvorín y La chispa que encendió la
Mecha llegó de forma inesperada y un
tanto curiosa mediante un censo
poblacional en el departamento de Santa
Cruz el feudo de la oposición fijaos
en octubre de 2022 el gobierno boliviano
retrasó la realización del censo de
población y vivienda hasta 2024 alegando
limitaciones por el tema Kobe 19 Bolivia
es un país unitario con autonomías es
decir los impuestos se centralizan y
posteriormente se distribuyen según la
población que tiene cada departamento de
igual forma la distribución de
representantes en la cámara de diputados
está sujeta al censo Y si este se
realiza este año tal y como corresponde
los resultados podrían aplicarse ya las
elecciones de 2025 las tendencias
demográficas de Santa Cruz La posicionan
como la jurisdicción que más atrae a la
migración interna por lo que es de
esperar que la distribución poblacional
haya cambiado considerablemente se
espera que esta jurisdicción consiga más
diputados y nuevas circunscripciones
donde el voto urbano gane terreno frente
al voto rural y claro siendo Santa Cruz
el gran bastión opositor el retraso del
censo fue algo así como una jugarreta
para favorecer al más en las elecciones
de 2025
como respuesta se convocó en esta región
un drásticamente total el cual duró 36
largos días en un contexto de fuertes
protestas que se saltaron con cuatro
fallecidos y casi 200 heridos
por supuesto la paralización del motor
productivo del país por más de un mes
provocó pérdidas multimillonarias para
la actividad económica paro en Santa
Cruz 35.000 bolivianos habrían perdido
su empleo según la confederación
nacional de micro y pequeña empresa de
Bolivia el Ministerio de economía y
finanzas públicas Calcula un daño
económico mayor a los 780 millones de
dólares por el paro Cívico en Santa Cruz
finalmente la cámara de diputados tuvo
que aprobar una ley sobre el
empadronamiento cumpliendo las
exigencias de Santa Cruz
[Música]
pero que ahí no quedó todo en medio de
las protestas el gobernador de Santa
Cruz Luis Camacho Sí el mismo que se
presentó en las elecciones de 2020 fue
detenido bajo todo tipo de acusaciones
racismo discriminación atentados contra
la libertad de trabajo atentados contra
la seguridad de los servicios públicos y
desórdenes o perturbaciones públicas Así
que sí el censo tendrá lugar pero la
oposición sigue sin dormir tranquila
esta vez queridos amigos amigas La
segunda gran crisis a la que se enfrenta
Bolivia pero aún nos queda la tercera la
crisis económica porque la pregunta es
puede llegar a quebrar Bolivia atentos
[Aplausos]
todos contra todos
[Música]
si bien durante su época como ministro
Arce logró mantener razonablemente
contenidos los incrementos de gasto
público ahora en su rol como presidente
ha tenido que enfrentarse a un clima
mucho más adverso Y es que veréis si
entre los años 2006 y 2014 Bolivia se
benefició de los precios al alza de las
materias primas a partir de Entonces la
cosa se dio la vuelta y el país comenzó
a experimentar grandes déficits por
cuenta corriente es decir que las
importaciones superaban por mucho a las
exportaciones poco a poco Esto fue
Vaciando la caja de Divisas extranjeras
del Banco Central para que os hagáis una
idea desde el año 2014 las reservas
extranjeras en Bolivia se han desplomado
más de un 75% a finales del primer
trimestre del 2023 por ejemplo el Banco
Central apenas tenían reservas
razonablemente líquidas unos 900
millones de dólares una cantidad
totalmente insuficiente para garantizar
los pagos al exterior del país la
situación es desesperada el gobierno ha
tenido que restringir la compra de
dólares y el miedo a que esto deje de
ser posible en cualquier momento hizo
que se formaran larguísimas Colas en las
entidades bancarias pero ese ese no es
el único problema para colmo el gobierno
también ha estado sufriendo desde el año
2014 enormes déficits públicos el
resultado pues vosotros mismos
perspectiva negativa amigos Ahora el
gobierno está intentando encontrar
nuevas formas de financiación y sabéis
que ha puesto su mirada en los fondos de
pensiones A ver no es algo nuevo pero sí
un paso que va mucho más allá tal y como
ya os contamos en política para patrón
desde hace más de un año el gobierno ha
estado emitiendo bonos soberanos a 20:35
años bonos que se los ha estado
colocando a los fondos de pensiones de
tal forma que aproximadamente un tercio
de los 24.000 millones de dólares de
ahorro en pensiones que tienen los
trabajadores bolivianos dependen ya de
la deuda pública Pues bien en abril del
2023 se decretó la estatización de todos
los fondos Es decir que ahora el estado
les va a colocar mucha más deuda pública
y eso no es todo a finales de abril el
gobierno también tuvo que intervenir el
banco fácil es decir que como veis la
cosa pues no pinta muy bien al menos en
el corto plazo a medio y largo para la
zona cosa podría ser diferente
y es que veréis el precio de las
materias primas está incrementando lo
que podría traducirse más ingresos
Fiscales y más Divisas a medio plazo
además el también está reduciendo las
ayudas como el subsidio de los
combustibles y está cambiando también la
ley para poder monetizar los 2500
millones de dólares en reservas de oro
que hoy no se pueden tocar y mientras
tanto Pues confían que la llegada de los
créditos internacionales en dólares sea
suficiente como para capear el temporal
Este es el plan veremos si da resultado
la cuestión ahora es que Evo Morales
está aprovechando el momento para
lanzarse a la yugular del gobierno Sí sí
lo habéis escuchado bien por ejemplo el
pasado 26 de Marzo el más cumplió 28
años la fecha era clave para buscar una
cierta Reconciliación pero nada más
lejos de la realidad Evo Morales cargó
contra Arce delante del propio
presidente y frente a las bases del
partido fijaos
presidente tiene que mejorar para hacer
una buena gestión política es importante
que no haya inflación
y no haya déficit pero sin expansión
económica recapitulemos la ruptura
dentro del más es prácticamente total el
2022 terminó con el principal centro
Industrial del país volcado contra el
gobierno la tensión con la oposición no
deja de crecer el recorte de subsidios y
la captura de los fondos de pensiones
está caldeando el ambiente social y para
colmo la crisis de Divisas pues puede
terminar traduciéndose nuevos problemas
es decir en otras palabras que la paz es
lo que menos probable parece en el
futuro de Bolivia estas que hemos visto
queridos amigos amigas son las tres
grandes crisis a las que se enfrenta
este país pero ahora la pregunta es
logrará Bolivia superar esta crisis de
Divisas podrá el gobierno por en el
orden las cuentas públicas qué ocurrirá
en 2025 se romperá el más presentarán
morales y Arce candidaturas separadas
déjanos como siempre tus impresiones en
los comentarios y hablamos debate y
ahora si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like y suscribiros si es que aún no
lo habéis hecho una vez más Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]